(audience applauding)
- Alright!
- Hello!
- Have y'all ever met before?
- No, no, I've never met!
- Never! Hi!
- Never met!
- [Kelly] Okay.
I was raving about you.
- It's an honor!
- Don't let me down.
- [Female Guest] (laughs)
- So, Neil, what is the coolest
new science thing you've
learned to tell me?
- I learn cool science things every day,
and sometimes I have to be re-- (laughs),
I have to be reminded of them.
Maybe I knew them long ago.
Like we all knew that we have
very high common DNA with chimpanzees.
Like 99% identical.
And you say, "Okay, I get that."
But do you know we also have 50%
common DNA with a banana?
(audience laughing)
- I do love bananas.
- My son, all he eats is bananas.
- Well, there you go!
And I got one other for you.
You ready?
If you look at the tree of life,
the common ancestors between humans
and mushrooms split after--
- What kind of mushrooms?
(audience and guests laughing)
- After the common ancestor,
between our common
ancestor and green plants.
Which means we and mushrooms
are more genetically connected
than either of us are to green plants.
- What?
- I know!
- We are like fungus sometimes.
- We are fungus among us, yeah.
- And--
- [Female Guest] Interesting!
- And some people have whole relationships
with mushrooms.
(audience laughing)
You know?
That's what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
- Yes, yes, they do.
- I know those people.
- [Neil] (laughs)
- And I'm like, "Be around people you love
and that love you!"
- So, these are new facts.
I'm more likely to learn a new fact
in a science that's not my specialty.
So, but I love learning.
- Me too.
If it's out of my specialty with science,
I'm just totally lost.
(audience and guests laughing)
Do you have any questions for Neil?
- Do I have questions?
Yes, yes.
Okay, I've been thinking
about this backstage.
Okay, if an asteroid
were coming to hit Earth,
how would we stop it?
I mean, this is possible, right?
- Oh, yeah.
So, we know exactly how to stop it.
- He knows the answer, right?
- Well, no, no, of course!
No, no.
So, there are two ways you could stop it.
One of them is the macho way.
- Blow it up?
- Blow the sucker out of the sky.
That's the answer.
- I'm from the South
- [Neil] Yeah.
(audience and guests laughing)
You-- (mumbles comically)
- [Kelly] Just shoot it!
- Yeah, shoot the sucker out of the sky!
- Who cares what the ramifications
for the rest of the universe are!
- This is what I'm saying!
In America, we know how to blow stuff up!
But we don't always know
where the pieces go!
'Cause if you blow it up,
now you can have two
parts that are gonna hit,
or all the pieces.
What's gonna happen?
So, a kinder, gentler
way is you go up there
and you nudge it out of harm's way.
If you get there early enough,
you nudge it a little, that accumulates,
and then it misses Earth entirely.
- What are you nudging it with? Like a--
- That's a good question! (laughs)
- Uh, 'scuse me, uh.
- An astronaut just goes up there
and just goes, "That way, bro."
(audience and guests laughing)
- So, there are ways you
can do it gravitationally
with what we call a gravitational tether.
So, you have another object,
and they attract each other.
And so, as they attract each other--
- Like a magnet?
- Well, with gravity, except, yeah.
Gravity.
- A gravity tether.
- Gravity tether.
- A gravity tether,
that's what I knew that.
Why are-- You should explain it to her.
I know.
- So, they attract each other,
but then this object you put up there
has rockets in it pulls aside,
and then they still attract each other.
And it slowly drags it out of harm's way.
That'll be a gravitational tractor.
- So, that would have
been a much easier ending
for all those movies.
- Like Armageddon!
- Yeah, yeah, then you don't get
the flood in New York and stuff like that.
- Blowing it up would be fun, too.
- So, here's the thing--
- Blow it up, yeah.
- We know how to do it from
an engineering point of view,
but there is no funded
project in the world
to actually make that happen.
So, we are just (slap) sitting ducks.
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
- Do you know this?
- That's comforting. Great.
- So, we're all gonna die!
(audience and guests laughing)
- Totally kidding.
- We need you to become engineers
so you can solve this problem.
- Yes, that's right!
(clapping and cheering)
- Work on the gravitational tether.
Well, tell us about the
new season of Cosmos.
- So, Cosmos, you know, it began in 1980
with Carl Sagan (imitates Carl Sagan).
"Billions--" I practiced
my "billions and billions."
And I had the honor,
his widow and co-creator
and co-writer, Ann
Druyan, invited me to host
a revival of that in 2014 and then
another season coming out 2020.
And so, this is the
continuation of this effort
to bring science to the public,
not in a preachy way, not in a sit down,
take your medicine, this is
science class, pay attention.
No!
In a way where you not only learn,
but you absorb the science in a way
that matters to you.
Where you are compelled to action.
Where you say--
- Inspires.
- It inspires!
Wow, I never knew that
and it effects this,
and our civilization depends on it.
I'm all in.
- And in that, we have to inspire them
to be a part of that.
(audience applauding)
- Well, I love you!
I love when you come on.
- This is the second time on the show!
- I know!
- I feel like a regular!
- You liked it!
You liked it!
You came back!
- Is this only your first time?
- Only my first time!
I'm a newbie here.
- Just follow me.
I'll teach you how to
come back a second time.
- Teach me all your ways.